desjardins annonce une stratégie pour
aider à la réouverture de l'économie
trois mesures sont annoncées
150 millions pour les projets en région
un fonds pour la croissance des
entreprises québécoises un partenariat
avec google également sur l'innovation
qui cormier pdg de desjardins il est
avec nous ce soir bonsoir monsieur
cormier ensemble c'est à dire alors 150
millions d'abord pour des projets au
québec en ontario en région d'ici 2024
d'abord est-ce que c'est de l'argent
totalement nouveau par rapport à ce que
vous faites généralement way est tout à
fait dans l'enfance et ses 150 millions
sur les prochaines années qu'on va
injecter donc on va prendre à même nos
excédents pour contribuer à stimuler la
relance à stimuler des projets vitalité
économique emploi jeunesse éducation
santé développement durable des projets
qui vont nous être présentée par le
milieu owen auquel il faut que nos
administrateurs de caisse et à faire
différents critères
on va aller de les rendre soutenait ces
projets de convergence et les conneries
oui donc quel type de projet vous nommer
des secteurs mais à quoi ça pourrait
ressembler concrètement pas je donne un
exemple il ya des endroits où on va nous
dire on aimerait je pense à charlevoix
que j'ai déjà rencontré il ya quelques
années quelques mois où on disait
l'emploi région c'est un défi garder nos
jeunes comment on peut garder nos jeunes
en région
alors déjà des idées justement partir
des entreprises ensemble mettre des
jeunes pour pouvoir se lancer en
affaires avait besoin d'un fonds voulait
l'ancienne et cuba par l'incubateur
d'entreprises alors ça pourrait prendre
cette formule au on est avec une
contribution financière à mettre de
l'avant avec les partenaires parfois de
la municipalité du milieux
gouvernementaux sur un exemple ou à des
projets reliés au développement durable
comment on peut aider des entreprises
dans des régions à pouvoir par le virage
vert avec des projets de biodiversité
sous lens a longtemps d'un apport
financier pour partir du projet alors ça
peut être une contribution financière
comme ça et aussi la vitalité des
milieux par rapport notamment l'achat
local partenariat avec la russie les
activités de ce nom ça aussi ça m'a mené
on va injecter des sommes additionnelles
pour déposer
locaux alors différents projets des
contributions financières ce ne sont pas
des prêts vous un artiste et de l'argent
exactement ce n'est pas un prêt il n'y a
pas de demande de remboursement
évidemment il va y avoir des critères
quand avatar si ces projets là on va
vouloir suivre les projets avec les
acteurs locaux au cours des années
suivantes
la force de ce qu'on fait c'est la
proximité des jardins que les milieux
tellement grande que d'autres directeurs
généraux nos administrateurs de
caennaise connaissent déjà tout le monde
dans le milieu les maires les élus les
promoteurs alors on va être capable avec
eux de travailler les projets puis au
fil des années on va pouvoir voir si le
projet fonctionne mais il n'y a pas de
remboursement c'est vraiment de
l'éjection de nouvel argent dans nos
milieux
quelqu'un qui a un projet qui nous
écoutent ce soir c'est à partir de
quelle date à quelle porte et doit
cogner exactement à partir de ce soir
après l'émission il communique avec son
directeur général de kayes communique
avec le président de la caisse et du dj
need et j'ai un projet est-ce qu'on peut
travailler ensemble et on est avant tout
une démarche qui va se mettre d'eux les
verts mais je pense que c'est la
première porte d'entrée dès le matin
peut communiquer jerez on sent un
engagement de la part de desjardins dans
cette crise là vous avez des capacités
financières est ce que cette crise-là
affecte moins les institutions
financières comme desjardins
bah écoutez je ne sais pas c'est
l'affect - la force du mouvement
desjardins c'est que nous sommes
beaucoup plus qu'une institution
financière nous sommes un groupe
financier très diversifiée des activités
de prêts aux entreprises d activité au
détail de l'epal un assureur vie un
assureur de dommages alors très
diversifié dont les impacts sont un peu
différent c'est ce qui nous donne une si
bonne capacité financière et vous les
mettez dans votre question
moi ce que je souhaite avec le message
qu'on lance aujourd'hui ses seins
on veut garder les milieux envie on veut
garder les entreprises en santé
contribuent à leur violence mais
deuxième maintient vers le leadership de
desjardins on veut inciter d'autres
entreprises à suivre puisque ont fait et
avoir le goût c'est contribuer à la
relance de la société
je pense que c'est aussi dans nos
missions chez des gens mais ce que je
veux dire aussi c'est que vous allez que
vous continuez en
allez continuez annoncé des excédents
des ristournes et il n'y a pas une mise
à pied le cd jardin en raison de la
coved 19 est ce que je me trompe
actuellement là on est en mesure d'avoir
85 à 90% de tous nos employés qui sont
aujourd'hui au travail en télétravail et
l'autre 10 15% et dans nos points de
service on a encore 300 330 points de
service d'ouvert en ontario et au québec
alors le mouvement desjardins opère
aujourd'hui la de façon efficace et il
n'ya pas les mises à pied parce que les
gens travaillent sur des projets appel
novembre sont en mesure d'avoir dans nos
centres d'appels des suivis notamment
sur des mesures d'allègement alors oui
aurons des résultats au premier
trimestre ils vont être clairement
affecter leur par rapport à la situation
notamment sur des marchés boursiers et
sur le ralentissement de l'économie
même mouvement desjardins je l' ai dit à
plusieurs occasions et bien capitalisée
très solide financièrement et on veut
contribuer à cette relance là alors
c'est pas qu'une question de générer des
excédents et des profits c'est tout
c'est une question de contribuer à la
relance de la société combien de
demandes dette jusqu'à maintenant vos
mômes blessure filer les reports de
paiements hypothécaires le code
d'urgence pour des entreprises
on a franchi le cap des 500 mille
demandes d'allègement qui ont été
autorisés par le mouvement desjardins
plus de 35000 près avec le comte
d'urgence au niveau du gouvernement
fédéral
et on voit ce ralentissement depuis une
semaine on voit que le gros des demandes
a été fait de la mi mars
à la fin mars peut-être justement la mi
avril
et là on voit qu'il est les mesures
gouvernementales fédérales et
provinciales
il ya de l'argent qui étaient jetés dans
les cordes mais c'est plus de 500 mille
demandes d'allègement qui n'était
autorisée jusqu'à m est ce que d'autres
mesures de soutien sont à venir je dois
vous dire qu'il ya toujours des gens qui
nous demandent pourquoi il ya encore des
taux d'intérêt élevés sur les cartes de
crédit
est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir des congés
d'intérêt sur les cartes de crédit
ben écoutez c'est pas une option que
l'on regarde avec seulement on a réduit
de façon importante à nos yeux les taux
d'intérêt sur les cartes et on est passé
de cartes qui étaient peut-être à 19
points quelques pour cent à 10 points
quelques pourcents pour les gens qui ont
des besoins d'allègement on va revoir
régulièrement
d'allègement encore la semaine dernière
il y avait des besoins au niveau de
l'assurance vie sont d assurance
dentaire
parce qu'elle est gentille mais
d'utiliser moins ses services au niveau
de l'assurance collective alors on en a
assez qu'on était les premiers le
permanent 16 mars a lancé ça on continue
de d'innover d'ajuster ça on s'est donné
trois mois ces mesures ne s'appliquent
pour trois mois à la mi juin
on va faire le point son sein qui encore
des besoins on réajuste par silvio lieu
mais aujourd'hui quand on regarde la
réaction normale
le panier de mesures d'allégement leur
semble adéquat merci beaucoup monsieur
cormier
merci monsieur fillon bonne soirée